the jurogan experience chris rock got so
big for a while that i think
people stopped paying the respect he
deserved 100 percent and i and when he
got covered i realized how just how
important chris rock was to me
like i like i just know you know because
i think norman just passed and i was the
biggest norm fan in the world and then
chris rock got sick and i and i i did
like a deep dive on my own head of like
just how [ __ ] great that guy is
well if you go back to like bigger and
blacker or you go back to bring the pain
bring the pain bring the pain those are
two of the best specials of all time
like if you want to look at your top 10
comedians of all time in my opinion you
have to have chris rock in there without
a doubt without a doubt there's no
questions about is the dark horse
hold on give me a second
man i have a lot of dark horses but i
don't know martin lawrence
martin lawrence in the 1990s so people
forgot you must be crazy dude are you so
crazy rather you're so crazy and he had
like a couple other specials that were
on that same level he had like two or
three specials that were like lightning
bolts and it's hard because you got to
compare them for the time like comedies
comedy's a weird thing man like even
like comedy movies from the 80s or 90s
that you thought were the [ __ ] some of
them just don't hold up for whatever
reason and stand-up comedy a lot of it
just seems different because the culture
so different because the world's like
everything's evolving and changing so
fast it's hard
but
there's a few guys from the 1990s that
would just
obliterate like you forgot how good
comics can be and i remember i saw
martin lawrence at the comedy store many
times like
7
10 times when he was in his prime
somewhere around then i remember he
would come by and just sell out the main
room and you would just sit there and
watch him murder i mean murder i wish
i'd seen that falling out of chairs
i mean screaming in agony because
they're laughing so hard and it was you
know this was 1994.
martin lawrence was the king dude i'm
telling you the thing the thing that
chris rock
brought and and uh once again i'm but
hold him let me tell you something
before we go any further yeah
one of the things that happened to chris
rock
was he had to follow martin lawrence
at the store no no they did a show
together and chris rock talked about it
he talked about it how forced him to
tighten up his act
because he had to follow martin lawrence
and he realized
no disrespect intended white people
he realized that he said that he'd been
playing in too many white rooms
and he realized like he had he had
gotten like a little bit
lazy or maybe a little slower than he
should be whatever he had to develop the
style that maybe wasn't he saw martin
crush and then he had a hard time after
yeah and then after that
you get some of the greatest chris rock
performances of all time after that you
get bring the pain after that you get
bigger and blacker after that you get
some of the greatest bits ever so he
he he's so like we all like every time
you've bombed how many times here it
goes right here he goes uh one night in
chicago as usual i was a headliner and
on this night my opening act was an
up-and-coming comic named martin
lawrence now normally
i never used to watch the opening acts
but i was in my dressing room and i
heard a roar
i got up to see what was going on i
thought it was a fight or something so i
got up and went to the side of the stage
when i got there i realized it wasn't a
fight it was people laughing so hard
that the building was shaking people
were crying standing stomping their feet
screaming laughter i was terrified it
was like watching somebody [ __ ] your
wife with a bigger dick
that's how good martin lawrence was i
followed martin lawrence almost every
time i worked on a night with martin
lawrence mitzi always made me follow
martin lawrence i never bombed harder
in my life
with three quarters of the audience is
walking out as you're going on stage i
mean three quarters that's how good
martin lawrence was in the 1990s i'm
telling you dude
i'm telling you i would watch him and i
was like this guy is like he's hitting
some crazy rpms you know if you have
like a sports car like 8 000 rpms is
crazy some of them go to 9. someone's
like
yeah you're like how long can you
go at that rpm like martin lawrence was
on this wild
rpm where he was he was crushing so hard
but then he had a bunch of issues and
then he had a sho he had a show martin
and then he had a bunch of issues you
know he had like like a like a breakdown
right remember that i do but i think a
lot of that stroke or something no no no
no i mean maybe i don't i don't think
about stroking us
or something no no no no no no i think
he had like some sort of a manic attack
and he got arrested from wearing like a
sweatsuit
no no it was like a wet suit
heat exhaustion from heat exhaustion for
preparing for big mama cells so he was
losing weight is that what he was doing
with the the wetsuit on he had to go on
ventilator
christ
but then they think that he had some an
episode
when i make his body temperature up to
107 degrees so something that could have
no i mean like a mental episode i mean
that made him think that that was a good
idea to do maybe i think i don't want to
judge him yeah i got to edit this
[ __ ]
martin too much editing see my thing
with martin lawrence is
and uh
is that martin lawrence seemed like
someone who was a is a god gift to him
right
like the the guy he was meant to be
super duper talented but he also worked
really hard man but that's the thing
with a guy like martin lawrence or jay-z
yeah it doesn't seem like they work hard
or richard pryor seems like or eddie
griffin seems like it just is what they
do you know well it's that too
you know there's a lot of those just
what they do guys that never get to that
level like what separates a guy like
that
you know from a guy who's just a funny
dude that we all know that we hang
around with at the store there's always
a guy who's just like really good and
they go on stage and they're really good
but they never figure out how to like
get to a place like those guys like
what's the difference well the
difference for me i mean i know for a
fact my difference is when i saw chris
rocney talk about how he trained for a
special i was like oh yeah that's that's
he would bring in comics and pay them to
watch his set and give him notes
like he was he was working in
collaboration with other people it was
like he had like a group of peers and he
would throw his ideas at them and say
you know like what do you think about in
the department maybe brilliant depaolo
rich voss
richard jenny was a big one was the
thing that happened
oh it says lawrence ran into traffic in
los angeles screaming and acting like a
madman that's what i remember okay
according to yes that's right big mama's
house after uh also had a loaded firearm
in his possession lawrence was removed
from the scene by law enforcement and
hospitalized martin was yelling
fight you know
don't give up fight the power or
something like that a witness told a
witness told cacao
he was shouting some obscenities or
something maybe he's just doing his act
maybe he's working on a bit yeah anyway
i'm a martin lawrence fan up and down
listen dude i'm telling you i am too but
i just think it's hard to be that good i
think there's something about being that
good as a guitarist or something to be
about good as a tennis player
or what a bike ride or whatever the [ __ ]
you are i was
i was just talking to a friend of mine
about a
tour de france and about uh lance
armstrong like how crazy you have to be
to be that good like to be that good
against other people who are just like
you like you have to be so god damn
driven that you're better than all these
other insanely driven [ __ ] like
you're dealing with like insane rpms man
[ __ ] insane insane watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify